hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
breaking the bonds not the bank new
possibilities with emissions ex d
cell i'm xavier gutierrez of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by agilent
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
please don't be shy to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send
please address each question to a
specific speaker
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speakers dr
christian klein
product manager of lc cudif and i am
cudoff at
agilent technologies and dr joe beckman
professor of biochemistry and biophysics
at oregon state university and cfo
of emission the court for a complete
biography
on dr christian klein and dr joe beckman
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr klein you may now begin the
presentation
hello i would like to welcome you to
agilent's virtual
mass spectacular webinar event series
and the topic here is breaking the bonds
but not the bank
electron fragmentation with the ext
option on agilent's lcq
my name is chris klein and i am the uh
elsecutof and i'm mobility
uh product manager with angela so
when we look into the different
application areas of ext
there's particularly one area which
shines of all of them and that is the
characterization and analysis of
biopharmaceuticals
so when we first look into this what are
actually biopharmaceuticals
it's a huge area from basically any
pharmaceutical drug
product manufactured in extracted from a
semi-synthesized from any kind of
biological sources
this can mean it comes maybe from living
cells like chronic program t
cells it can be somatic or germline gene
crp like crisp or cas9
it can come from blood or blood
components auxins or anti-toxins
a scenes it can be other things like for
example breast milk or fecal microbiota
but very much common for the current
uh drugs are the recombinant proteins
and antibodies like insulin and
particularly monoclonal
so when looking at monoclonal antibodies
the first thing of course is
they are big and to put that into a
percentage in here
if you look at a biologic like herceptin
and compared to a traditional drug like
a lipitor
just see already that from the molecular
weight we talk about 185 thousands in
the case of receptor
and only about 559 for lipitor
so putting those into a perspective it
is a comparison of a two-story single
family
uh family residential compared to the
empire state building
so whereas for example you can do very
well with a regular home inspection for
your
single family doing the same home
inspection for the empire step building
most likely will be incomplete and
insufficient at all
this of course then puts it to the next
steps that for the characterization of
biotherapeutics
a huge number of methods is needed in
order to characterize those later
hopefully
billion dollar blockbusters as
efficiently as possible
so we talk here about the truncation of
lysine which typically happens to buy
and exchange chromatography
fragmentation which can be also on the
hinge region over reversed phase
diameter oxidation pyrolytimic analysis
disofit shuffling or precise exclusion
chromatography some aggregation
and of course healing placed or
glycosylation
most of these methods nevertheless are
still feasible to address by lcms
that can be the intact mass intact
protein quant
drug antibody a ratio calculation native
ms
fragment mass identification charge
variance
a positive translation modification the
identification and localization
and of course glycan id so all of those
effectively huge handbook of analytical
chemistry
it is kind of evolving on here but if we
look into the small aspect of what do
all of those methods have in common
the answer is very simple they will all
give additional answers with ecd
and this is actually the power of the
emissions
exe cell which allows us now to add a
completely new dimension
of analytical technology to already
existing separation technologies
but looking into it in a different
format of the additional
answers given here in the gas phase
reaction
so the method has already moved well
beyond its original
pure academic uh research and
example for this is really shown here
over the vast biology of our
early exterior adopters we see a good
mixture of academics
as well as biopharma industry on here
and based on that we actually can say
together agilent animation
moved what has once been an academic
field of ext
into a hopefully new step in the
analysis
of biopharmaceuticals and with this i
want to give the floor to
joe backman ceo of emission and thank
you for your attention
joe it's your turn thank you chris
and thank you everybody for joining us
for this virtual
seminar i'm very excited to tell you
today about some of the developments
that we've
been working on at admission that can
greatly improve the coverage
and the utility of using a qtof
which will greatly expand its role in
proteomics
my name is joe beckman i'm a professor
of biochemistry at oregon state
university
and based on technology that we
developed at oregon state
we've launched a company called emission
and we've been working with
agilent for a number of years
to bring a new form of electron-based
fragmentation to their instruments
and we have here a photograph in the
basement of the
egg life sciences building at oregon
state
where kathy costello was visiting us as
well as ken newton from agilent
technologies and rebecca glasgon who's
now at agilent
and i'm there with doug borowski and
valerie voinov the inventors of the
technology and yuri vasilev
who's one of the co-founders with us
and we basically have been developing
this technology for almost
for at least 10 years we've then
when this photograph was taken it was
the day where we started to fragment
ubiquitin
in a tightly compacted form and it
became very clear how powerful
the cell is for this technology and
it allows you to avoid many of the
problems that are encountered with other
fragmentation technologies such as etd
so about five years ago we formed the
company emission
which is an amalgam of e for electron ms
for mass spec and ion for ion
and our goal is to make ecd as widely
available as possible
so shown is the original cell that we
were developing at osu
and over several years we've refined
this to become a very practical
addition that's now available at agilent
utah systems
we've grown to be 24 employees and we
now have seven sbirs funded as of last
night
and a major part of what we've been
doing for these few years is developing
automatic tuning and control of the ecd
cell to integrate with the agilent qtof
we passed all the regulatory hurdles and
the providing warranty
issues and how we're going to service
this technology with agilent
and we've developed a number of powerful
new applications that i'll share with
you today
that really extend what you can do in
very exciting ways with proteins and
other compounds
so the technology is shown here that
we're providing
a replacement part for the collision
cell that includes the electron based
fragmentation
the ecd cell on the front and basically
it takes
an hour or so to install the cell and to
re-pump the instrument
so it's a direct replacement all the
functionality of cid is still retained
this instrument still behaves with ms1
ms2
it still tunes using agilent swarm tune
procedure
but you have to do a few additional
steps i'll show you in a second
to make the ecd cell work and there are
a lot of different software
flows that can give you better protein
characterization the main respon
um advantage of this technology and it's
very fast
and so it keeps up with uplc
capillary electrophoresis and even eye
mobility
so it's the only technology that really
works well after i
mobility separations for electron-based
fragmentation
so if we imagine the cell was basically
a cloud of electrons and sitting in
front of the
collision cell we can illustrate the
advantages here
and we can take a tightly folded protein
such as ubiquitin bring it into the cell
it can capture
an electron and that will induce bond
breakage
but we have the advantage that we can
put that into the collision cell now
and separate many of the fragments
and that allows us to get better
coverage than you can by other methods
we can also activate the ion
the protein ion before it enters the
electron cloud so this can be done by
collision-induced unfolding or even
adding energy
in the front end of the system and that
activated complex allows for better
electron-based fragmentation
this is an advantage over etd
where you have to cool the protein ion
and then mix it with a negatively
charged
electron transfer agent and that cooling
causes the protein to fold back onto
itself
and then to uh that creates problems
with causing dissociation
afterwards and we'll show examples of
this where we can
get better coverage than what you can
with
currently possible with etd
so the cell itself is actually a pretty
simple device
in principle it has two magnets
that basically create a magnetic field
and it has a hot filament that's
producing
uh electrons much in the same way as old
vacuum tubes did
then there's a series of dc electrodes
that are used to
first pull electrons off from the
filament and into the magnetic field
and then outer electrodes that confine
the electrons to the inside of the
device
and also help to focus ions as they
transfer are transported through the
cell
there's no trapping ions pass the speed
that they enter the cell with and emerge
from the other side
and in the few microseconds that takes
the fragmentation process
has taken uh has already happened
so the key is the magnetic fields hold
electrons in a very compact
area and that allows enough electrons to
be
stored to create a very efficient
fragmentation process
now the tuning of this is actually not
very complicated
and we show how this is done if you put
zero volts
on each of the lens elements and we are
going to use our software so we're going
to use agilent's cal mix
or called two mix here and we're just
measuring the transfer of all these
different ions through the cd cell and
on into the top
and basically with zero volts applied a
few thousand ions
will make it through the cell if you
start from the middle and work
out that we will first apply
a dc voltage to the filament and then to
its holder
and you can see the ramping occurring
uh and we'll get a a significant
increase in
ions transmitted the next step after we
pick the optimum
uh for transmission for the middle
elements that are
we then tune the two magnets that's
shown here in step b
and you get a very dramatic increase in
transmission
notice that there's a very sharp
drop-off or a valley afterwards
and that results because as you increase
the voltage applied to the dc element
pretty soon the the electrostatic lens
will block ion transmission because the
voltage is higher
than the ion energy passing through the
cell
we continue with this ramping so um next
we
tune the outer uh lenses and then
finally the outermost lens
and that gives transmission that's very
similar to what you would get if there
was no ecd installed
the tuning for ecd is similar
but you have to take into account the
trapping of electrons and that's also
done automatically
and these profiles are saved and you
will
tune slightly differently for a peptide
versus a protein
and most of the difference comes from
having to change the way that
uh ions the protein ions are passing
through
the cell itself that you have a much
bigger
molecule and so changing the outer lens
elements makes a bit of a difference in
how good transmission is and how good
how well the ecd fragmentation works
now to talk briefly about fragmentation
uh
first with peptides collision-induced
dissociation
uh will typically break at the weakest
bond and the peptide passing through the
collision cell will make thousands of
collisions with gas molecules
that gradually add energy throughout the
entire molecule
and that causes peptide bonds to break
typically between
the carbon and the the nitrogen is shown
here to produce b and y ions
one of the challenges though is it also
induces a lot of
other losses including
post-translational modifications
neutral losses and if you add enough
energy
you can get internal cleavage which
becomes very hard to predict
so cid is extremely efficient
and it works well but it produces fairly
complex in noisy spectrum
electron capture though involves
typically a nitrogen
an electron combining within your the
nitrogen and it breaks
the bond on the opposite side so it
produces c and z
ions and notice that the z ion remains a
free radical
and that electron can migrate so
you can get secondary fragmentation
occurring with ecd
processes and that can be extremely
valuable
as shown here so if the electron moves
to the side chain
you can get neutral losses of a
ethyl versus isopropyl group from
isoleucine
and leucine respectively and that means
that you can use
these w ions that are produced to
distinguish isobaric modifications
in addition it's not uncommon to get a
ions
produced with ecd process where we're
breaking the peptide
bond in a different place so you can get
a lot of information up by combining ecd
with cid
and using these to increase your
certainty
and your analytical identifications and
we can show that
well there's one further use of this and
that is that a common
uh modification that happens in proteins
is the isomerization of aspartame or
aspartate
to iso aspartate and that's shown here
so for the ant antibody herceptin that's
used to treat breast cancer
one isomerization can cause a 70
loss of activity and it turns out that
there's an enormous amount of
isomerization occurring in proteins that
are important in neurodegeneration
such as a beta and alpha synuclein
and electron based fragmentation allows
you to see these fragments
which you can't see with cid or these
rearrangements
and that's shown here that you can get
bond breakage so typically with iso
aspartate
in addition to getting a z ion
fragmentation you can get a z
minus 57 mass so
to show this we had a peptide made
which we playfully made the peptide ecd
is so delightful and in this spectrum
you can see
that the iso aspartate or iso d here
has a very nice minus z57
but in addition there are a lot of other
ions that are formed in here
including many w ions which we highlight
here
so that in addition to getting iso
aspartate we're able to distinguish
leucine from isoleucine and then
aspartate loses the carbon dioxide
and it forms its own d ions so that can
be seen
and cysteine also forms uh
w ions and so you can identify a lot of
modifications to cysteine using this
technology
so with etd you can also distinguish iso
aspartate
but in our experience the w ions can be
more difficult to distinguish and that
has to do
with the cooling of ions and getting the
transfer
so you can get quite a bit of a
fragmentation out of this from a doubly
charged peptide
i should also add that this peptide of
this spectrum was collected as part of
an
auto msms run on an agilent h
system using an hplc separation and we
collected both the two and the three
plus charge state as well as
ms-1 so it's part of a standard workflow
for doing uh
bottom-up proteomics there are a number
of other examples of how useful the
electron-based fragmentation using our
ext cell can be
and we identify learned a while ago
that the two plus charge states of many
phosphopeptides are very hard to
fragment
particularly if they contain an arginine
or an r group
and that's shown down below
where this arginine will actually form
ionic interactions and that will inhibit
a lot of the fragmentation
so we published on this a number of
years ago when we were first starting on
the technology
and this was another example that we
were working with
with our cell you can get a very nice uh
fragmentation pattern where you can just
walk up
and see where the phosphoserine is and
get the entire sequence
but when we tried this on a very
high-end
system equipped with etd
the fragmentation actually was quite
limited towards the amino terminus
and that again is due to that arginine
wrapping around with the phosphoserine
now in this particular run we've used 10
milliseconds of etd
time we can increase the etd time and
get much more
consumption of the precursor as shown
here and
but that actually didn't help the
coverage actually decreased
and notice the magnification that we're
using down in this low end it's 5000
in the 10 millisecond range and 25
100 up in the the higher mass or with
the longer etd
time so what's happening here
is with the longer ett time there's more
electron transfer to the precursor and
it's actually going completely
to a neutral state and you see a loss of
a precursor without an increase in
fragmentation
and the difference that we're getting
with our cell is the fact that our ions
are more activated
as they're passing through the cell and
that allows them to dissociate more
completely
this is similar results that were shown
in a poster here at the
asms meeting by kiki hawkinson's group
and this was done on a 6560 agilent
system so this is an immobility equipped
qtop
so here's data on the high end
etd system and it's a palmetto
modification
on the cysteine shown in the star and
here's the spectrum that's obtained on
the 6560
so it's much richer coverage now in this
system it's possible to add additional
energy to the
precursor before it enters into our ecd
cell
and you can get even more efficient
fragmentation occurring
so uh that's shown on the poster from
kiki's group
and i highly recommend you check that
out
now on the high end or on the
uh ion mobility systems we're able to
actually follow off the
in fragment ions as they come out of the
immobility cell
because it only takes about 10
microseconds for
proteins and peptides to reverse our
cell
so the fragmentation here is far faster
than most processes that occur
that are used in mass spectrometry
and this was our first example so this
was
done in kathy costello's lab at boston
university
a number of years ago and what we were
showing is the three plus
charge state of substance p
will be separated into two conformers
where the c
terminus is actually folded in or
extended
we had a very beautiful ecd spectrum
from both sides
and you can actually see less
fragmentation in the compact structure
at the carboxy terminus
we've several groups have extended this
and rotillo's group has a number of nice
demonstrations of using our ecd cell in
the 6560.
now dr wu at agilent
decided to take on the hupo
phosphopeptide challenge
about two years ago and
hubo is providing about 200 different
peptides that are known to be
problematic in bottom-up proteomics
for identifying phosphorylation sites
and so he used the agilent system he
used the assay map bravo
to start to to enrich for
phosphopeptides
he used the standard workflow on the
qtof
and then used cid to identify the
peptides
but to identify where the
phosphorylation sites
were he used our ecd cell and so
coming back and looking at that he was
able to identify 92 out of the 94 sites
and here's one example from his
application note that's referenced at
the bottom here
where the top is the cid spectrum and
then there's a series of three ecd
spectra
that show where the phosphorylations
were found now
each of these uh identifications was
based on a single spectrum that was
analyzed by
the bionics platform and i wanted to
show you though that
if you look work across the peak and
average the spectra together just how
rich the spectrum is
and that's shown here is that we've
extracted one of these peaks
so you can see where diluted by the
extracted chromatogram
and if you look at the bottom spectrum
doesn't look very impressive
until you start zoom in and when you do
that
you can see how rich the spectrum is you
can easily identify where the
phospho-serine group is
for both sites
and each of the fragments that's
identified above actually has
up to five different fragments that
show that what this is very specifically
so we get golden triplets which are a
combination of a b
and c ions um in this spectrum
and golden dopplets coming from the uh
carboxy terminus
of z and y ions and i think that's
what's really powerful with this
is that you can get much better
identifications rather than relying
on a single fragment
coming out from a bottom of proteomics
but it's also very clear that electron
capture processes really
aren't meant for doing doubly charged
peptides or it's very
it costs you a lot of sensitivity part
of the reason is half of the ions that
are
produced half the fragments have
captured an electron or nuke
and or now neutrals
but if you go to larger more highly
charged states the ecd process
becomes much more efficient and so this
is showing just a few minutes of data
collected on ubiquitin and the six plus
charge state which is a tightly folded
state
and you have a beautiful spectrum from
both the carboxy
end and the amino end that you can read
all the way through and the coverage is
97
so the three amino acids that were not
cleaved are prolines
which are not expected to cleave by
electron-based fragmentation processes
in addition shown in the blue boxes are
a series of leucines and isoleucines
that also appeared in the spectrum so
we're also able to distinguish
these two isobaric modifications that's
really important for doing uh
accurate de novo sequencing or uh to
improve identifications because 16
of the human proteome is either leucine
or isoleucine
and hence invisible by standard cid
methodologies
so electron capture increases with a
square charge
and as you start to go to bigger
fragments or bigger
peptide fragments or entire proteins the
efficiency of the cell
increases quite dramatically
so on a standard cutoff proteins up to
15 kilodaltons are actually sequenced
quite well on chromatographic time
scales
and a big advantage of going to bigger
peptides is you can look at the
arrangements of ptms
along the modification along the peptide
chain
it's a little crazy to think that you
chop a signal
a protein into lots of pieces and then
you
try to reconstruct actually where are
all the ptms and which ones correlate
with which
and that's what really excites us about
what we can do with this
new technology so one example
is some work that we've done with uh
blaine roberts
who was at the florey institute in
melbourne and he's just recently moved
to emory
so um i have to admit in the fairness
that
blaine is actually a really good friend
and he did his phd with me about 12
years ago
so i flew over we installed the cell we
started to collect data
and this is a chromatogram of a human
brain homogenate that's been undergone
acetone precipitation
so pulls out proteins under 20 000
and so this is a chromatogram this was
run a day after we installed the cell
and we were looking at it going through
that evening and
this arrow was what agility calls the
walking man
so at this point the spectrum popped up
and i said plane that looks like
ubiquitin
and he said i know i've analyzed this uh
mixture on lots and lots of different
proteins or
mass spectrometers and i never found
ubiquitin in it either by bottom up or
top down
but in fact if you look very closely at
the ms2 we have 70 80 percent
sequence coverage based on single scans
coming off this chromatogram
so here we're doing discovery work on a
qtof
in an auto ms mode and in this case we
identified
five or six different proteins out of
the human brain very quickly
while i was visiting uh we went to
lauren to a proteomics conference and i
met chester drum who gave a really
fascinating talk about his work on
uh thymozine beta iv
and this is elevated in
human i have a dog at my feet that's
just nagging for a tree
so excuse me for a second okay
so thymozine is a
really good marker uh for a problem in
heart disease
and um diastolic heart failure
in women but he had a problem with being
able to identify
where the post-translational
modifications were and
even getting fragmentation by cid so we
adopted that as a standard and have been
using it
actually in a mixture that i'll show you
in a second
but let me just show you the how easy it
is to actually
determine what the entire sequence is of
a
a common small protein in blood
so here's a chromatogram that we've run
in a standard mode we sum these peaks
together
we average the data as an mgf file which
basically exports the centroids
we're loading this into a open source
program called
lcms spectator and there are a number of
different programs that can be used but
this is a really convenient
program for us and here shows part of
the spectrum the peaks identified
and the bottom shows the coverage map
that we've completely sequenced the um
this
pro small protein from both directions
now this is actually the protein mix
that we're using
uh and we've combined a number of
different proteins so
thymosine was just a very convenient one
that we can get from sigma
we're using bigger proteins like
cytochrome c ubiquitin myoglobin
and the coverage that we got from the
single chromatogram is shown here
so uh we can get really nice coverage
for most of these proteins
now carbonic anhydrase the coverage is
fairly small
at 40 percent but that would be high for
an hcd run
but i'll show you in a second that with
a little bit longer we can actually
sequence it in a native state and get
remarkable coverage
and i'm going to show you insulin in a
minute that this protein
has its disulfides intact we can
actually map the disulfides in a
chromatographic rung
single run so this is showing insulin
and it's uh
it's folded state it has a zinc bound to
it
and this is the ecd spectrum that we've
collected
and we have to do add a little bit of
cid energy about 30 ev
in order to get the protein to unfold so
we get really a nice series of
c ions uh near the immunoterminus and c
ions from the carboxy terminus but when
we added the zinc
or model to zinc into the binding site
then suddenly we got
uh a lot of z
ions that extended to the meanest amino
terminus
and c ions that extend it to the carboxy
terminals in other words we're able to
get both ends
by uh fragments from both sides
and this is far more coverage than most
people have ever observed from native
carbonic anhydrase and just to show you
what this indicates is a bit how the
protein unfolds
so you can overlap these two
and you'll see that you have essentially
the same maps for both
z and c ions that gives you a lot of
confidence about how the protein
unfolds and this is a really powerful
new approach that you could apply with
iom mobility
on the 6560 and if you add
collision-induced unfolding you can
actually
follow what happens as you add more
energy to cause a protein to
run to unravel and then apply ecd
and this is some studies that have been
done by brandon rotillo's group that are
reported here
on proteins like bsa that are really
impressive results
now coming back to insulin this is a
single run
and from insulin and this is showing
just an expanded region
of the top spectrum that comes out
and the spectrum is going to be low and
have relatively small peaks
but remember there's no smoothing or
signal processing which is done
automatically on an orbit trap
if you're using an orbit trap technology
remember that they typically report the
resolution at 200 or 400
and that every time you double the mass
range the resolution decreases by a
factor of two
so that's a challenge uh our qtos
actually work quite well
out in the higher mass range where we're
doing these
top-down approaches in fragmentation to
get very high resolution spectra
what was really impressive uh with this
is the amount of coverage we could get
because
insulin has three disulfides there are
two the whole two uh
protein chains together and one internal
intramolecular disulfide and that's
shown here
and we're able in that single run to be
able to identify the fragmentation map
all the way across
so we were getting fragmentation not
only of a file but also of
the backbones that allow you to unravel
what is the
the actual sequence here and that's
shown here
where we use we're basically going to
search
and we're going to imagine that this
bond is broken so we
use the cysteines as dehydrocysteines
they're missing a hydrogen atom and here
we model this cysteine as having a
post-translational modification which is
the entire a chain
and when you do that you can find a very
rich fragmentation pattern
corresponding to the entire b chain
conversely we can look for the a chain
using the b chain as opposed to
translational modification and we can
identify this site
um or we can identify all the sequences
on both sides
but the internal disulfide has no
fragments in it
and what we found is another set of
spectra where if this bond is broken
this disulfide is also broken and then
we can get a few fragments
inside of this region
so that's a pretty remarkable result
it's
proved to be very valuable for a number
of different cysteine knob proteins
and we have one poster here by mike here
illustrating the use for three different
proteins
and the real value uh is going to turn
out to be
in analyzing antibodies so jared shaw
has recently joined the company
but while he was at pacific northwest
labs he published a nice paper
um showing that he can identify
which light chain is bound to which
heavy chain basically identifying
uh chain pairing because our ecd cell
was breaking
this sulfhydro bond and releasing it
and this is shown here where we've taken
the intact antibody under denaturing
conditions
and we're performing ecd on all the ions
all the different charge states here and
we get a series
of
light chain charge states that are
released from it
as well as a lot of ecd fragments that
are shown down here
and the coverage is actually pretty
amazing so
we've now been working on identifying
what these peaks are
and we get pretty good coverage of both
the all three cdr
determining domains as well as the chain
pairing
and that's done in just a few minutes of
data collection on the native protein
we also uh have very high efficiencies
so
we've been collaborating with dr liang
lang sun and his graduate student
uh xiao chenzhing
shown here on the left and we're using a
new interface for capillary
electrophoresis developed by cmp
scientific
and here are a series of proteins run in
a standard
and they've repeated the injection three
times to show the reproducibility
i actually cut off a number of
additional uh
runs just to save space and then
averaging across there
is the coverage that we can get for
myoglobin and for sod
on these chromatographic runs so
it makes top-down proteomics really
practical
on a qtof system
there's one additional big advantage
that we have
and that is that we can produce much
more energetic electrons than is
possible with etd
we simply increase the voltage
difference between the filament
and the rest of the ecd cell the
electrons come off with much more energy
they have enough energy that they will
actually
knock another electron off a peptide
or another analyte molecule so
here what we've done is we've selected
one plus
substance p and we're tuning the cell
so that we produce the two plus species
uh and the two plus species is shown
over here with only one hydrogen atom on
it
and when you do that when you do it's
essentially hot ecd
or eid
you actually get a very nice
fragmentation pattern but we're
producing a ions
in some side chain fragments of d ions
so it gives you yet another way to
identify fragments and get more
certainty about what you're looking at
now the real value of this we believe is
going to be in analyzing glycans
and so here we've used the one plus
glycan a carbos it's a diabetic drug
it has one amino group shown here
and in green we show cross ring cuts
that we're observing with high energy
electrons
in essence the electron has enough
energy that can break two bonds in a
ring simultaneously
and that's shown in this spectrum where
we have the cid spectrum
that just produces a few fragment ions
based on the
like breaking glycosidic bonds but we
have a much richer fragmentation
with the ext cell producing higher
energy fragments
now um we have this uh as a poster by
diana oppenheimer at the meeting
and kathy costello's group has got a
variety of different
demonstrations using the ecd cell to
produce
better glycosidic identifications
so to summarize this is a very practical
method for implementing electron
fragmentation
it's available now it adds a lot of
capabilities to the instrument
with uh without really losing
the abilities that you have now it
enables
top and middle down proteomics with
really fantastic sequence coverage
uh for proteins up to sixteen thousand
it works higher than that
it's just the sequence coverage starts
getting a bit comp
congested so it works with itis digested
antibodies
i showed the results of actually using
native antibodies because of
the ability to break disulfides and it
has a lot of advantages for both bottom
up
and middle down in being able to map and
quantify post-translational
modifications
distinguish iso aspartame from aspartate
distinguishing leucine from isoleucine
and first starting to map where
glycans are located and they're
branching patterns
so we're quite excited to be partnering
with agilent and making this technology
available
and with that i'll be happy to take
questions thank you so much for your
attention
and we hope to be hearing from you
thank you dr klein and dr beckman for
your four-day presentation
now we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started our first question is
what is the difference between etd ecd
and exd
so i'll go ahead and start basically etd
is offered it has to have a negatively
charged reagent mixed with it
and it is uh a more common technology
that's being used these days but it does
cool ions so it keeps them
the big problem that is et node that you
get
charge reduction without fragmentation
an ecd was originally developed in high
end instruments it was only available on
fticrs so never really gained that much
in popularity
but it has one other challenge when you
do this in a high vacuum of an fticr
and that is that the electron can be
captured but there's no further
activation
so people would add infrared lasers and
do other things to try to get
dissociation
but we've discovered with our cell that
we're getting much better coverage
simply uh because ions can be activated
in the higher pressure regions
and we're finding that we're getting
better fragmentation
and more richer fragmentation spectra
with the exp
cell
excellent the next question is uh will
this technology work with
a tough no quadrupole
in principle there's no problem doing
that um
in practice we've designed the ecd cell
to fit on the
collision cell afterwards so we've not
in
actually put this into a toff yet
if there's enough interest we could
certainly do that
it's not a technically a major challenge
to make that happen
i believe there's some advantages in
working with things like
capillary electrophoresis and
isoelectric focusing that the top has
some direct advantages
use a better separation technique on the
front
and then you can just use the top
and how well does the exd cell work with
native proteins
i think that's what's been a really nice
uh surprise for us is that it works
really well with native proteins
better than uh as well as better than
denature proteins so the challenge with
native proteins is they're tightly
folded and they tend not to dissociate
and what we're finding is that
we can provide different amounts of
activation
to get better fragmentation and just
start to separate the pieces
so that the coverage works well the
advantage too of the native protein is
it's not
doesn't occur in as many charged states
and that simplifies the spectrum
and it gives a cleaner less congested
spectrum that becomes easier to analyze
all right and looks like we have time
for one more question
can the exd cell yield multiple
desolified cleavages with intact
antibodies
so we showed the results with the um
with insulin and other small cysteine
knot proteins and that's generated a lot
of interest
that we're getting multiple disulfide
cleavages on a very rapid time scale
and with uh we're also discovering
that's the case with the antibodies that
we're getting much deeper coverage
than people have seen before and we're
clearly breaking at least two
or three disulfides
to be able to get the coverage that
we're generating
excellent thank you gentlemen for your
answers and do you have any final
comments for our audience
well it's been a very strange experience
giving this talk or recording it when
dogs were coming in thunderstorms were
coming having to stop
so i appreciate everybody hanging in
there a lot of
information was presented in the asms
conference i was referring to
so there's a number of posters and
presentations that
would be worth looking into to get more
information about
the technology and some of its
applications by different end users
yeah i would also like to thank the
audience for uh participating
and uh i hope you're also getting as
excited as i am about the capability
that agilent can offer now together with
emission
on ecd as joe has mentioned this is
really a track which we were working on
for over 10 years so to finally see this
emerging into the field seeing really
early adopters in the industry and the
academics using it
i'm really excited to see all the new
opportunities now
with exd on agilent's instrumentation
and thank you again for the
participation
well thank you again gentlemen for your
time today and your important research
we really appreciate it before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june of 2021
until next time goodbye
all right so we're off